good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you come out so you can have a positive
impact on yourself on your family your
community and the world so to help you
on your journey today's message is break
the limits over to you APJ Abdul Kalam
[Music]
history has proved our history has
proven that those who dare to imagine
the impossible are the ones who break
all the human limitations in every field
of human endeavor whether science
medicine sports are the technology the
names of the people just know I listed
some of the names the names of the
people who imagine the impossible are
engraved in our history by breaking the
limits of their imagination by breaking
their limits of their imagination a
change they change the world
you take CV Raman you take Newton you
take a Einstein you take Chandra Shekar
thereby breaking the limits of very
major imagination they change the world
the biggest limits that we face in life
are not from our friends and not from
our family and not from the people
around us it's you it's ourselves you
put the limits on yourself you are
restricting yourself but the story that
you continue to tell yourself but what
you think you can and cannot do and the
question I always ask is when did you
decide to accept those limitations when
did you decide that it was okay to live
small and to say that yes I cannot go
off and do amazing things when did that
become part of your story and when are
you gonna decide to break free and say I
want something better I want to create
more for myself in my family and my
community in the world and the people
around me when are you gonna break free
of the shackles that you put on yourself
we're too off more complaining about how
other people are restricting us the
biggest limit of all is you I think
about my career as an entrepreneur and
when I first started my first biotech
software company I was 19 years old and
I used to think I was too young to sell
that was my limitation I was my limited
belief I was too young people wouldn't
take me seriously I was 19 years old
selling to people three times my age I
didn't have a background in science I
didn't think they would take me as a
credible source and so I played small
and so I would send out emails and so I
would never schedule meetings and so I
would never do phone calls I'd always
try to hide behind the persona so they
would never know how old I was and it
wasn't really until I started realizing
that listen they don't care how old I am
all they care is that I can provide
value and that started to shift the
limit started to break free like ah
maybe I can do this maybe it can't be
more maybe I can have a bigger impact
than this little box that somehow I put
myself into as I started helping out
entrepreneurs and I started growing my
business I used to always think too that
I had to wear a suit you know I always
wore suit in my day to day I wouldn't
wear a suit but if I ever had a meeting
I would wear a suit and it was just
feeling like they wouldn't take me
seriously if I didn't have a suit on you
know that I look young and in that I
couldn't bring enough value and then
slowly over the years I got a little
more and more and more myself I took off
the suit and just had a blazer or a
jacket and then I went to a sweater and
then you know slowly I evolved and I
came out of my shell and I again refused
to accept that box refuse accept that
for me to be taken seriously I had to
wear suit but it took a long time to get
there like I wish I had somebody shake
me and say it doesn't matter doesn't
matter if you are in a suit be yourself
stop restricting yourself when I started
this business of helping entrepreneurs
it didn't start on YouTube it started on
my website and the websites off my name
Evan Carmichael and I would always
create profiles the famous entrepreneurs
I was inspired by their stories and we
had you know all the people that I
profiled here Oprah and Bill Gates and
Steve Jobs and Richard Branson all these
people would profile on the website and
the number one request that people kept
coming in with was who's Evan what's
your story why aren't you up here and my
thoughts were always well I'm not I'm
not big enough I haven't done as much as
Oprah and Bill Gates and these huge
people
I'm not worthy to be on that site even
though is off of my own name and it
really came down to is my story is
valuable my journey is valuable people
can learn from what I've gone through
even if I haven't achieved as much as
Steve Jobs and Bill Gates and it was
just a mind twist to get over that you
know even on this channel the most
requested top ten rules is is me is
myself and it took a while to come out
of my shell and get in front of the
camera and be willing to share my store
and share my opinions and it comes from
the belief that my opinions matter my
opinions mean something because I would
always hide behind these celebrities and
famous profiles and so like when did I
decide to accept that box it wasn't
anybody putting me in that box I put
myself in that box
and just decided to burst through it
right the side is say I don't accept
that limitation anymore to believe more
in myself to have more confidence to
feel like what I do matters and so it
encouraged you to look at your own life
and think what are the what are the
limitations that you put it on yourself
what are the reasons why you feel you
can't go off and do the thing that you
want to do and once you get past like
blaming and complaining other people
restrictions that are being put on you
think about what are you telling
yourself and as soon as you can break
free of that limitation break out of
that box and say I no longer accept this
about myself I am NOT that person I
don't know when I decided to accept that
but it's not anymore that person doesn't
exist anymore I can bring a lot more
value to the people around me into the
world than what I used to do and the
only difference is getting your mindset
aligned on it so the question I have for
you today is what is the biggest
limitation that you need to break free
up for yourself share it down the
count's below declare it unleash it let
it go by leaving in the comments so that
you can live a more impactful life and
for those of you who are watching
encourage others who are leaving
comments show them a little bit of love
and support because this is believe
nation we're in this together to try to
make the world a better place I'm really
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say I also want to give a quick shout
out to Candice Saunders Candice thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word I really really
appreciate the support and I hope
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
for me as a driver I just could I change
I improve all the time through
experiences not race by race not just
race by race but in life you know I'm
always taking all these different
experiences positive and negative
extracting the best bits out of them
learning becoming older and wiser
I mean I'm 23 years old I think I'm
quite wise for my age I think I still
got a long way to go but but then when
it comes to driving I just I I excel I
I pushed beyond limits when I'm training
I go beyond the pain barriers I just do
everything I can to make sure that when
I arrive at the racetrack I've already
got to three tenths on the other guys
I'm a storyteller and I I'm not someone
who restricts myself to one thing ever
I've never been that person maybe I have
EDD but I want to be able to do
everything why can't we do everything
sure you know as and especially women we
are great at multitasking so I want to
produce I want to have a business I'm
gonna I'm producing here I'm gonna
produce in India Hindi films regional
films and I want to be able to act in
them maybe not you know there's so many
things that I can do which I want to be
able to explore the greatest compliment
I think I've ever gotten better than
Oscar better than Grammy etc was towards
the end of the last Dark Knight Rises
you know working with those
percussionist that we've just sampled
these guys have played on everything
there they are the guys you know there's
and there's nothing they haven't played
so my great ambition has always been to
go and do just one thing where they go
wow I haven't done that before I
actually figured something I've noticed
I'm not gonna go into the details but
you know number one I got the compliment
of crying wow we've never done this
before and it sounds really good
lolz volume you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be kind
of like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details